Hello Parker nice to meet you and
congratulations hi Perry thank you nice
to meet you
so going back to the very beginning when
you first started developing the idea I
was wondering if you ever played around
with any other physical representations
of evil or if you always knew it had to
be a smile and nothing else you know uh
the smile definitely hooked me from uh
the very beginning you know I love sort
of that inherent contradiction that
exists within it the you know Smiles are
obviously designed to be a friendly
gesture something warm that's what we
associate with them but in reality I
think we also we use Smiles every day to
mask what we're really feeling and uh
that was definitely something that was
you know um a motif that was running
through the film and I want to see if I
could take that and turn on the head and
and kind of let the evil in the film
wear a smile as a mask to sort of you
know create the promise of a threat or
something dangerous something menacing
and see if audiences uh might uh you
know get freaked out by that literally
every time I smile during this interview
I'm going to be judging myself now
that's me all day every day now here's
another thing I was curious about
because you know when we have something
like a slasher movie and you have like a
ghost face Michael Jace and it's really
easy to obviously name the evil entity
so I was curious did you ever come up
with you know a name whether it was for
the evil entity or what it turns a
character into when it consumes them you
know we had some uh nicknames uh during
production but for me you know for the
for the purposes of the story it was
always really important that we don't
Define it we don't stick it in any kind
of box because I think that the you know
the unknown is always much scarier than
uh than when you sort of pull the veil
off of it and you know I also love the
ambiguity that the that the film is
living in you know there's there's
something really interesting about
taking something so internal and
psychological and then something so
external and and like bombastic and kind
of braiding them together until they're
kind of indistinguishable and I'm I'm
hoping that you know that'll go like the
extra disc to get under audience's skins
I'll warn you I'm a big old lore nerd so
I got a couple questions later on that
you probably won't want to answer but
first this might sound like a more
trivial thing to ask about but I was
really curious about coming up with the
title card at the beginning of the movie
because I think that might be one of my
absolute favorites of the Year oh wow
thank you I appreciate that
um yeah no we um I from the beginning I
knew I kind of wanted to have this sort
of extended introduction to the film
where you're kind of holding your breath
waiting for some you you can feel you
know very off-kilter that something
terrible is coming your way sort of
hurtling at you
um and so when it finally happens I
wanted to
you know have this incredibly menacing
uh kind of
crazy making moment uh with the title to
really you know slam audiences back in
their seats spot on in that respect I
love that so much I have another very
specific question for you how exactly do
you direct someone when you need them to
smile what actual like verbal
instruction do you give them when they
have to put on that demonic like grin
um well so you know it all started uh
while I was writing the script um I was
trying different things in the mirror
myself uh trying to figure out what
might work and then when we're on set um
it was about I mean certainly people
came in very prepared uh with what they
had been working on and then it's just
about kind of standing a few feet away
from each other and smiling back and
forth until we could dial it in and get
it just right and yeah I'm really really
pleased with it and it was also really
important to me that those were
practical performance-based Smiles uh
because I think that adds a level of uh
and uncanniness to them please tell me
there's b-roll of this somewhere uh yeah
I'm sure it exists somewhere definitely
we're going back to what you were saying
about you yourself testing out Smiles
can you kind of give us a sense of like
the two pull most polar opposite types
of smiles you were considering running
with for the film you know um I for me I
I think that there was uh I wanted
something that felt Frozen and kind of
uh
predatory like like an animal you know
in an interesting way and to remove any
sense of humanity and lifelessness from
it
um there there was the other end of the
spectrum that was you know sort of
like almost like too bizarre that that
felt kind of outlandish and Goofy and it
was about finding the right place in the
middle all right fair enough all right
I'll put up the spoiler warning for our
viewers at this point so that you could
talk about these next few things freely
but this is this is kind of like a lore
like the nature of the evil type
question here but I was curious if you
ever considered if it was possible for
this entity to infect more than one
person at once like if multiple people
had seen them take their own life would
all of those people then be infected
that's a really fantastic question and
it's definitely one we we were talking
about and discussing and um you know I
think uh
I think that the evil in the film is
incredibly specific and I think you know
as we start to uh peel back the layers
and learn more of of what its intentions
are and how it works um I like to think
that even by the end of the film uh it
might still have more surprises in store
for us all right so speaking of the
specificity there can you tell me a
little bit about figuring out which
victim sees which individual when they
are infected and were there ever were
there ever any times when you were like
debating on who they should see and when
yeah you know I wanted to hopefully
um I think the idea was to
find ways to make it really surprising
and subverting expectations about
um how and when the smile was going to
appear
and to not let it just be one thing to
constantly be evolving and changing and
you know it it when you realize that it
can be a total stranger or it can be
somebody that you know or somebody who
shouldn't even be able to be in the room
with you
um you know it really sort of uh forces
the audience to to you know really put
their guards up and not trust anything
in the film which was the the hope uh
here here's like the biggest question of
the bunch I could ask you about what it
means to work with this evil entity but
have you thought much about if there's
any possibility of actually being able
to beat it or is it just this this
vicious cycle that someone is trapped in
no matter what they do you know it's a
it's a good question
um I like to think that um
you know this thing it's sort of it's
sort of uh it sort of enjoys toying with
uh its victims and and and being as
Elusive and slippery as possible
um I like to think there probably is a
way to to beat it but
um
but I don't know I mean it it it's it's
also quite inescapable maybe it'll take
you a couple more films to figure out
what that answer is so then smile can
become a franchise well we'll see I'm
rooting for you all right I'll end with
this one here of all of these super
elaborate you know scare or effects
heavy set pieces in the film was there
any particular one where on the day
while filming you stopped and thought
like man this is big how are we gonna
pull this off and then you and the crew
rallied and you did it
um yeah so there's a lot of different
moments that I could speak to but
certainly uh the very end of the film
when we finally uh get a glimpse of uh
what's kind of been hiding behind the uh
the the smile this whole time
um that was an enormous logistical
challenge it was very important that I
knew from the beginning I wanted to do
it practically and uh and you know I got
to work with some some Legends in that
field
um over at Studio ADI and you know that
was a an image I had drawn very early on
and worked with a concept artist to take
further and um when we were we actually
shot that at the very end of production
because we needed all that Runway to get
there and when that was there on Set uh
everybody was gathered around sort of it
felt like a like a pinch me dream come
true moment to get to do something and
create true you know movie Magic you
could not have teamed with a better
group of people to create something like
that it looks excellent oh thank you
they are gonna kick me out of here I
have to let you go but thank thank you
so much and huge congratulations on
smile thank you so much I really
appreciate it it's great speaking